plus que demain au non moins que demain
plus qui a pu tain c'est quoi déjà
allez bonne journée
non mais tu vas ou au bureau jeter ses
virées le mois dernier jérémy je sais
que c'est dur mais face alors que
d'arrêter dans le déni le point positif
c'est qu'on peut déjeuner chez mes
parents en ce moment rien trois ans
décidément si oui mais non vous êtes
trompés là c'est pas la bonne alliance
si si si mais ce que vous avez grave et
c'est parce que je vous ai demandé on
n'a pas dû bien se comprendre au
téléphone
comment ça plus qui hier moins que de
merde
ah oui mais aussi si vous articulé pas
bon c'est tellement grosses qu'on vit ça
me rappel sévère de paul eluard les
plaines tout petit dans mes mains
ouvertes dans leur double horizon inerte
indifférent le front en vitre comme font
les veilleurs de chagrin je te cherche
par-delà moi même par delà la tente et
je ne sais plus temps je t'aime lequel
de nous deux est absent
e
maître corbeau sur un arbre perché plus
que n'en attend pas moins qu'hier plus
que demain